from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in Italy and the US
this is food
Wars in Italy our drinks come in three
sizes small medium and large we're going
to measure the large one to see how much
it actually
contains that's supposed to be 500 mL I
think we're getting close to 600
actually 140 ml extra Burger King in the
US our Fountain drinks comeing four
sizes value small medium and large and
the large is 38 flu ounces or
1,120 ML and now I would like to measure
the largest and see if that's exactly
how much they gave
us it's almost exactly 32 fluid ounces
it's not close to 38 Oz yeah it says 38
in the bottom here hey someone who works
at Burger King or someone who works in
fast food why why why why do they say
here's how big the cup is and then
clearly it's not that amount what am I
missing here every single place does it
here in Italy we have three sizes of
fries small medium and large Burger King
in the US they got four fries sizes over
here's a value then the small the medium
and the
large so I know that in food War's
history Burger King is actually lied to
us so let's see if they've been honest
with me today in Italy and measure every
single one of them the sizes are working
now the small is actually smaller than
the medium I have no proof of this I
think they saw our Us versus UK Burger
King episode saw us some call out #
frate 2021 when 2020 and uh they're
running scared but they
still trying to pull it over a US
Whopper the Whopper is a fantastic
sandwich on to the nuggets in Italy they
come in three sizes a six piece nine
piece and 20 piece in the US our nuggets
come in three sizes uh two if you go
into the restaurant apparently you get
the four piece or the eight piece but
also on Uber Eats an exclusive
apparently you get a 16 piece both Italy
and the US serve onion rings in Italy
they come in8 piece 12
piece and 16
piece so we have four onion ring sizes
and I want to point out that for us we
just do it by cup size we're not doing
it by number of onion rings like they do
in Italy I have to
say they were very generous with the
onion rings at ours I mean this is the
value this thing is overflowing with
onion rings a small medium and
large here's everything that you can
find at Burger King in Italy that you
won't find in the US and here's
everything you can find in the menu at a
US Burger King you can't get in Italy
let's start with the burgers in Italy we
have the Italian King collection which
comprises these two burgers here the
first one is the pahan and scamorza
burger scamorza is a cheese from South
Italy where I'm from so scamorza it's a
bit like a mozzarella in a away like
they come from the same family of
cheeses uh they're made in a similar way
but scorta it's like aged for like a
week like not so much so it's like a
hard mozzarella let's see how it tastes
in a
burger nice
not a fan of the onions I think they
overpower a little bit the taste of the
cheese without maybe the PTY it does
seem like a traditional Italian sandwich
and then we have the parmesan Burger
this one has bacon in it apparently when
Burger King launched this burger they
had to buy something like 500 wheels of
Parmesan reano which is like parmesan in
Italy they are the same thing um so
quite a lot of wheel
um I don't know it feels like a dream to
be in one of those rooms with like 500
wheels of
parmeson it feels like I don't know next
time you do it please call me Burger
King I'm coming to collect the
cheese better this one than the other
one this one is a little bit less messy
the flavors come out individually I can
taste everything yeah I like this one
always on the parmesan team and then we
got the Big King this is supposed to be
Burger King's uh version of the Big Mac
this one uh it's slightly different to
the US uh because it has an extra bun in
the middle and apparently has Special
Sauce that's supposed to taste like
Thousand Island sauce very yellowy I
never had Thousand Island sauce I don't
think I've ever seen it even in a
supermarket this is a bit vinegary like
a bit like tartar sauce in a way
but I don't know I'm not a fan but I
don't know maybe that's just like the
aftertaste of pickles that's also
something I don't like I know Joe
doesn't like them so yeah there's two of
us yes Claudia dislikes pickles too I'm
so happy to hear that Claudia has
impeccable taste so for her to dislike
pickles must mean that I also have
impeccable taste so me and Claudia no
pickle friends and then we've got the
bacon Burger King 3.0 it's got three of
everything it's got three patties three
cheeses and actually eight strips of
bacon it's so heavy I mean I'm gonna
take this to the gym to use as like a
proper weight it just looks gross it
looks like I don't know like cementon I
don't know how this is an exclusive to
Italy I feel like if I want to indulge
I'll just have two of something else
that's a little bit less messy there are
eight strips of bacon though and
apparently they are different in Italy
than in the US so let's have a look and
then we've got the Bronx
Steakhouse if you are from the Bronx
does this look familiar to you and then
we have the uh veggie
Steakhouse same thing just with a veggie
poty what is this it's like veggy bacon
the first time I see it why is it
brown it looks like a
candy tastes like salt and like frying
oil not so much
like
bacon yeah does give you the feeling of
like just having a regular burger if
this is not technically vegetarian
because it's cooked on the same Grill as
the meat Patty I guess this is a burger
for people that eat meat that want try a
veggie option the veggie Steakhouse that
might be a translation error I don't
know if it could be a veggie and a
steakhous then we've got the big king
XXL so bigger size than this one uh this
one is has got two patties four cheeses
and a special sauce bigger onions as
well then we have the plant-based
Whopper and then we got the crazy Cheese
Whopper this one is a delivery exclusive
apparently for the cheese lovers to be
honest as a cheese lover what is this
amount of cheese just it's ridiculous
there was more in any other any other
Burger it's just for the lovers of like
weirdly hanging strips of bacon maybe
all right us Burger exclusive options
starting right here got the bacon
cheeseburger look how small this is by
the way but as you can see Burger got
bacon and cheese believe it moving on to
the impossible Whopper I think that's
this one with the lettuce yep impossible
is a brand of plant-based meat here in
the United States that is just that made
from Plants no animals were harmed in
the making of this burger I think
something that should be noted there is
disclaimer on theg Burger King website
that says our impossible meat is cooked
in the same Broiler as the regular meat
and also the mail on these Burgers does
have eggs in it so uh good effort Texas
Double Whopper come on Texas Texas is a
state in the United States that does
everything bigger so of course they have
their own Whopper it's a Double Whopper
double the size of regular Whopper look
at this it's got double the meat see
that and jalapenos on here although
they're kind of not existent but they're
on there in the US we have the single
quarter pound King you saw that earlier
I absolutely destroyed it I threw it
away but also we have a single
impossible King same thing as the
impossible Whopper why am I talking like
this uh look at that I mean you could
put this melted cheese on a piece of
shoe leather and I wouldn't know the
difference we also have a bacon Whopper
Jr which I they didn't give us also a
Big King which they did not give us I'm
certain I ordered it anyway we do have
is this the Rodeo Burger haow is a
burger with barbecue sauce and onion
rings man really generous with the onion
rings fun fact about the rodeo
cheeseburger it was created to coincide
with the release of the film Small
Soldiers in 1998 another fun fact in
1998 I worked at a movie theater in
Shamburg Illinois that showed Small
Soldiers this was for some reason
brought out in time with that movie was
in the dollar menu stayed on the menu I
guess you can see why fun little burger
and the small solders chip Hazard which
is the name of the character I don't
even know his name was advertised it by
saying you can't handle the bur which
just like Jack Nicholson's line from A
Few Good Men you can't handle the truth
here are all the chicken items that you
can get a Burger King in Italy starting
from the crunch chicken fried chicken
mayo lettos and tomato you can also get
a chicken bacon King same thing as the U
beef one with a eight strips of bacon
next up we have the chicken roal with
bacon cheese
why is this this shape does this look
Royal to you maybe it's just easier to
eat I don't know but I'm not very
intrigued a lot of mayo here and then we
got the crazy cheese chicken bcq yeah
there's definitely barbecue sauce here
and then we got a plant-based nugget
Burger which has mayo that is not vegan
because obviously there's eggs in there
but there are three nuggets in there
just funny like a nugget burger here are
most of the chicken options you can get
at the US Burger King starting down here
we got the BK Royal crispy chicken every
time we do a food Wars Burger King's got
a bunch of new chicken sandwiches cuz
they're trying to compete with
Chick-fil-A and if you ask me they
losing all right this looks epitome of
just okay we also have a spicy version
of the same sandwich the spicy BK Royal
crispy sandwich this one looks
crispier much better not very spicy good
flavor to it get that one you also have
a bacon and swiss one which I think is
this one all right I want to get a bite
of the bacon in the
SS taste bacony typical the Burger King
something's popular so they make a
somewhat inferior version you can also
get the honey mustard VK Royal Crisp
Chicken blahy
blah this one also has bacon on it the
Honey Mustard's interesting we also have
chicken junr it's a little guy this is
basically uh the Ripoff of the McChicken
a far more Superior chicken
sandwich another menu item that was
available over the summer but may be off
the menu now certainly wasn't the BK we
went to here in Burbank was the Italian
BK Royal crispy chicken let's get that
picture up on the screen this would been
perfect for food Wars US versus Italy
couldn't get my hands on it Claudia what
do you think of this I don't know that
doesn't look very Italian to me I think
if you put crispy chicken that
automatically makes it all Italian let's
talk about wraps we thought they were
two uh actually the grilled chicken is
not uh there anymore so we just got this
crispy one these wraps look very sad I
don't know I feel like you could do
better with the actual wrap itself
here's what inside what's inside I don't
know the wrap is very pale BK also has
wraps you can get pretty much each one
of these chicken sandwiches in wrap form
I went ahead and got the spicy BK Royal
crispy wrap I mean all they're doing is
taking oh so it's half a Patty I a full
Patty so you get half a Patty and all
stuff in wrap form like what is the
what's the draw of this if you want to
wrap just go someplace else couple other
exclusive items that we got here you get
a taco of Burger King I love tacos just
as much as the next guy but I mean look
how thin this is look like the I sat on
it before he gave it to us I'm
curious I can't be sure but I think they
put the barbecue sauce in there that
can't be rip if they did that's terrible
whatever it is it's bad don't get it
this right here is the big fish look at
this thing what a nightmare they put
pickles on it guys come on pickles on a
fish sandwich I really like the filo
fish I should say that right now I think
it's a tasty sandwich I don't know what
they're putting in the F fish in
McDonald's probably not a lot of fish
but I think it's very good my favorite
thing about the F fish is their tartar
sauce it makes and breaks the sandwich
for them tarar sauce fantastic so one
would assume
that this Square fish Patty uh correct
me wrong but no fish is naturally Square
so this highly processed fish Patty uh
is drowning in a white sauce that should
be a tartter sauce and we're going to
find out if it's any
good it's a thicker
bun feels like getting more sandwich um
yeah I actually kind of like that I
don't think it's better tasting than the
flil fish but still pretty good let's
see what is in Italy's King Junior your
meal as a main course you can either get
a four piece nugget a chicken burger a
hamburger a cheeseburger or a toast
which is what we've got today and then
you also get fries a mini kit cat a
drink and a toy let's see what's inside
ours here's our
toast tiny
fries KitKat the drink obviously and a
toy what is this it's like a
glass it doesn't really look like
something you would give to your child
if you were making their lunch it is the
plainest thing that you can get and
usually parents are a little bit wary of
like giving sauces and like things that
are too rich kids meal options in the US
AKA The King Jor you can get either a
cheeseburger or a four piece nugget I
think we got the nuggets and then
options are either fries onion rings or
applesauce uh they have a drink cup that
is
reusable I think it's pretty nice and
you can also get milk see it says Junior
right there and for a
toy spoon no the toy they got nothing I
don't know if they forgot to give us a
toy or maybe they don't have
toys what like oh you think cuz I
ordered as an adult they're like he
doesn't want a
toy what all work and no play for the J
man come on I want a toy I think maybe
though you think the puzzle's the toy in
the
big I don't
know so I don't think the spoon's the
toy so either forgot the toy you don't
get
one we didn't get one exclusive sides we
have these are two of them uh one thing
I want to point everyone's attention to
are these chicken fries that's right
chicken strips shaped like fries
interesting fact about this box it kind
of like get smaller here this box was
designed specific specifically to fit in
a car cup holder cuz here in America God
forbid we stop and eat a meal we have to
eat and do something else I think it's
very funny consider in Italy it's like
the meal is the event and a chicken fry
it's more of like a marketing thing to
call this a fry because it's not a
chicken tender because tenders come from
a specific part of the chicken the fry
is more like a chicken finger or it's
made with whole muscle meat they're
really durable they're really elastic
don't you think if you're waving a piece
of chicken like this it would have
broken off by now look at this look at
this why is this so like this I think
they taste fine it's just a weird thing
to be like on the menu still I don't
know anyone who's getting these
mozzarella sticks we should have asked
Claudia before do mozzarella sticks even
exist in Italy I want to know cuz here
in the US you can get these as a four
piece or an eight piece with marinara
sauce these have been sitting for a
while but of course course I'm wondering
what kind of cheese pull we can get from
these mozzarella
sticks
oh okay okay oh not a bad one that's
just okay these are our exclusive sides
here in Italy starting from these chili
cheese bites you can get them in a six
piece and a nine piece doesn't look like
there's chili in them let's try them
out they taste a bit too peppery
I was expecting it just to taste spicy
like they taste like fresh chilies which
is nice but I'm not sure which cheese is
this then we've got plant-based nuggets
as a six piece they look a bit green
like there's been like there from filter
on them they taste actually like nuggets
I don't know if this
is like fake chicken or it's just like
vegetable vegetables but they're quite
good and from the inside they look like
normal ones you can then get get bacon
King fries with cheddar sauce you can
also get them without cheddar sauce but
here's the ones we've got you can also
get chicken wings in a four piece and a
eight piece here's how they look like
just very tiny wings when I was little
we used to go and like vacation in this
town in like the south of Italy like a
very small village and the whole village
on the 15th of August was celebrating
with something that we call the Alat
allaha means Wing in Italian and it was
just like a big chicken wings party the
ones I'm used to they were a little bit
bigger uh and a bit more like light
colored let's see how the this ones
stayes
like oo
spicy it's like a bit Yeah like a bit of
a spicy sauce yeah there's a lot of
pepper in there no not a fun that then
you can get two types of toast the king
toast with a Swiss cheese and ham this
is the same as in the kids menu and then
you can get it with bacon and American
cheese and then we've got griller fries
or maybe you call this waffle fries but
we actually have some packaged uh chips
in Italy they are sold with this shape
perhaps that's why they went with the
fries there is a tiny bit of spice um in
the after like in the after taste quite
nice they're doing waffle fries in Italy
that's a direct ripoff of the chickfila
fries like this company is
Shameless if it's popular somewhere else
Burger King has it that's their new
slogan and then we also have salads here
in Italy technically there are four
options but we were only able to get two
so the four options are just a mix salad
uh crispy chicken um grilled chicken and
a tuna salad which which doesn't seem
like something I would like to get
Burger King here we have a mixed salad
one thing I just why are you serving the
salad with the whole tomato who eats
this like why and we have another one
here which was supposed to be the grill
chicken I think but
uh it's another one of those mixed
salads with those huge Tomatoes The
salads can also come with some olive oil
it was actually given to us in a little
sashet but we can't find it sauce
talk sace talk here are all the sauces
that are exclusive to Italy well
technically exclusive because they're
all from Hines um so you won't find this
in the US hin makes all the sauces here
in Italy we start from ketchup then Mayo
barbecue sweet and sour sauce Curry
mango sauce then we've got spicy tomato
salsa which um sounds interesting and
then we got cream honey mustard the last
one which is not made uh by hin is not
Chola this is technically not a sauce
it's like a hazelnuts and chocolate
spread a bit like Nutella yeah this one
Roni Diago is like some people will say
the Posh Nutella it's a very nice and
Rich spread let's see mango and Curry
the color I was expecting nice I'm
surprised it's on the menu yeah it does
taste like Cur inspired sauce and like
sweet so maybe there is mango I love the
looks in the mango Curry I definitely
want one of those can you please send it
to me thank you here are pretty much all
the sauces you can get in the US since
they're not Hines products at least not
labeled do you think Burger K can makes
their own sauces or you think they're
just get going to the source and putting
their own labels on it I have no idea
here we got a barbecue
sauce I would love to try when I go to
Europe like that's happening anytime
soon when I go to Europe I want to try
their barbecue sauces I feel like what
they think is barbecue and what we call
barbecue can't be the same that's a
sweet barbecue sauce I'd like in like a
Kansas City Barbecue very good this is
the zesty sauce this tastes like a
strong mustard not honey mustard but
sweeter than a regular mustard actually
it's close like a Deon it just says
spices doesn't say which ones um no it's
not bad just I don't want that sweet and
sour sauce come on oh open like a normal
imagine if I was driving trying to he
might chicken
ah I be on the opposite side of the road
by now crashing everyone I be driving on
the sidewalk trying to open this the
sauce all right sweet and sour come on
Buffalo sauce for those you not in
America buffalo sauce is named after
Buffalo Hot Wings it's a type of spicy
sauce get wings and now it's on
everything and know it does not taste
like Buffalo it's from Buffalo New York
where the sauce was the recipe was made
or perfected I don't know so basically
hot wing
sauce
I like buffalo sauce I don't think it's
only good on chicken and burgers or
fries are dipping doesn't work last we
got Ranch this country is obsessed with
ranch I don't know why um it's kind of
weird but we got everyone in America
including Burger King
so ranchy and this is uh Hines ketchup
wait we have hind ketchup and they have
hind ketchup so this is an
exclusive but these sauces are biscuits
here in the the us we have a specific
type of biscuit that is not a cookie or
a scone it's its own thing anyway we can
get just about every breakfast sandwich
at Burger King in biscuit form there's
the bacon egg and cheese biscuit sausage
egg and cheese biscuit Smoky Maple
chicken biscuit the ham egg and cheese
biscuit the egg and cheese biscuit and
the fully loaded biscuit I'm not getting
all them it's a waste here's two I got
the bacon egg and cheese biscuit
personally I think when it comes to
breakfast sandwich bacon egg and cheese
is the gold standard you can maybe do do
it a different way but I think bacon egg
and cheese is pretty much the best
breakfast sandwich to get there it is
there's your egg there's your bacon and
cheese there's the biscuit it's very dry
I don't feel like trying it and then
also the fully loaded one this is
hilarious want to get this this got a
little bit of everything got the egg got
the sausage got the ham got the cheese
and the bacon how does this look Italy
huh breakfast is served let's go not
only do we have that in biscuit form we
have the same exact type of sandwiches
in croissant excuse me cand form once
again Italy your neighbors to the north
France they invented the croissant I'm
sure all through Europe you have amazing
pastries including croissants here in
the US we've absolutely ruined them by
cutting them in half and sticking meat
and cheese in the middle so here we go
we got the bacon egg and cheese again
the gold standard you also get a ham egg
and cheese egg and cheese Smoky Maple
chicken Cris sandwich that's horrible
double sausage egg and cheese I forgot
about that that's two patties of sausage
two slices of cheese double the diary in
the morning and of course the fully
loaded CR
sandwich our cricket buddy is
back we will try to remove the cricket
audio in uh post but sorry everyone
we're filming this in the middle of the
woods apparently we have sausage egg ham
bacon cheese oh
God C do you want to bite to this we
also have breakfast burritos this here
is the egg normous burrito which has
bacon egg cheese a hash brown and a
spicy sauce this is for someone who just
wants your first hour once you punching
at work to be on the toilet so if you're
looking to poop on company time maybe
grab one of these and'll way to work
look at this guys this is
like I don't even know what this is like
I've never seen anything like this so of
course I have to try
it nope gross and this next
one is a breakfast burrito Jr so this
one's for kids want to get them started
young look what they did they put a hash
brown at the beginning and the end so
you're going to be
like oh it must be loaded with hash
browns one of the one of the entrance in
the exit nice s also in the US we're
crazy about pancakes and we have the
pancake platter and the pancake and
sausage platter currently unavailable at
the Burbank Burger King in Italy we
actually don't have a breakfast menu a
Burger King to be honest I don't think
Italians would like to have what Joe has
in his menu like across some filled with
bacon and eggs doesn't seem quite right
uh I think most of us just have a sweet
breakfast that usually is just the
pastry and the coffee it can be a very
calorific pastry with like a lot of
Nutella or another feeling but usually
it's always sweet sounds like Claudia is
implying that Italians like something a
little more sweet a baked good for
breakfast so we do have some of those in
the US and we do have some of those
obviously have Burger King going on down
here starting off we got French toast
sticks France as you are aware is a
country that's right above Italy and
they have their own toast and we have
that in Stick form and this is them and
it also comes with the dipping syrup
what's more French than that look at
this look at this I know it's food Wars
Italy food Wars France has got to be
right around the corner any french
person watching this right now is going
to have a heart attack but yeah you know
I
mean you have no idea how sweet this is
uh also we have these hash brown bites
little
guys desserts sweet oh how we have it in
the us at our Burger King uh you can get
a Hershey's Sunday pie not Sunday day of
the week Sunday as in uh like a ice
cream sunday right and I mean I look at
this look at this right look at this how
gooey that is ooh come
on also at Burger King you can get soft
serve ice cream I didn't get it because
we've been in the studio for a couple
hours and it's very hot and it would
have melt anyway you can also get
chocolate chip cookies hey and a variety
of shakes a vanilla shake a chocolate
shake a chocolate Oreo shake and this
the Oreo shake every time we do a fast
food place it has a shake that the Oreo
shake I get it I think that Oreo as far
as branded cookies snack shakes you get
a lot of these fast food places the Oreo
is the best one why do you ask looks
like a vanilla and chocolate shake right
wrong it isn't vanilla it's the it's the
Oreo cream flavored shake with Oreo
chocolate cookies in it just I'm telling
you oh my God so good Oreo is the best
shake hands down M so onto the dessert
options here in Italy these are the ones
that we were able to get but actually
there are a bunch of others and we're
going to put them all on screen here
that includes a lot of ice cream like
sanday and milkshakes but we were not
able to get them so this is what we've
got today we've got noata pancakes and
then we've got Nati uh cheesecake Crown
caramel sule I think if you call
something lava cake you would expect I
mean I'm sure like half of your
customers will think that you actually
put lava in there yeah and I was saying
earlier not cha is actually a very
popular spread here in Italy it's like a
Haz and that and chocolate spread I was
expecting it to be much
thicker let's
see quite
nice yeah p pancakes are okay it's
really delicious it tastes much strong
like much more like like hazelnuts than
Nutella does like these two are like
competitors approved we can also get
some milkshakes the exclusive ones are
NES quick NES Cafe and Oreo drinks to
the US Burger King we have a lot
Fountain drinks for instance it's a
fountain drink cup I wasn't going to get
all these cuz it's just super hot it's
pain in the butt to get the stuff here
all the other drinks have melted told
I'm wearing the shirt it's hot in here
we have something called frozen drinks
you get a frozen Coke and a frozen wild
cherry and also Frozen blue raspberry
which is not available um this was more
of a slush consistency for melted in
this 80° Studio what oh we also got milk
okay anyway
um not bad I mean it's still pretty cold
but yeah usually this is a lot more like
ice like icy there a wild cherry oh yeah
we do have coffee drinks you can get an
iced coffee this used to have ice in it
and a hot coffee and of course who
doesn't like to relax with a room
temperature fat free milk that'll wash
down your burger here are all the drinks
that exclusive to Italy Burger King
starting from this very cute P orange
juice then we got some uh some tea we've
got Peach and Rose fancy and lemon and
lemongrass we've got Monster Energy uh
which has been delivered in a bit of a
funny shape and then we've got beer you
can either get hinin or nusa which is a
Sardinian beer some Burger Kings will
also serve a full range of coffees
espresso coffees cuz that's what coffee
means to us uh but because we got our
food and drinks delivered we actually
were not able to select coffee so we we
couldn't get any
today
Burger King in my point of view is like
Fast food's little brother it's always
like trying to trying to be like the big
dogs it's always trying to be like
McDonald's it's always like whatever is
Good Burger King has like kind of a
later crummier version of it now I will
say the Whopper is a fantastic sandwich
I love the Whopper I get it occasionally
but everything else on Burger King's
menu thumbs down or at least there's
something that's better than whatever
they're offering you know Burger King I
only eat there when it's the ultimate
convenience which is rare because I
don't know if a lot of people outside of
the US knew this but Burger King's
strategy is to build a location close to
a McDonald's did you know that so
McDonald's does all this research about
where to position their restaurant
strategically you know traffic patterns
uh rent in locations all that stuff
McDonald's is the whole department of
people to figure that out and then
Burger King's like all right we'll build
one across the street from the
McDonald's that's for real like that's
their Vibe on everything so I don't know
it's like in other countries but in
Burger King you're just like oh Burger
King in Italy I think Burger King goes
pretty much hand inhand with McDonald's
um obviously it's been there for a
little bit less time Burger King is
quite popular in Italy they currently
have 232 Outlets KFC has only got 50
branches here in Italy although they are
still behind McDonald's that has 630
branches like some of us have most of us
have celebrated birthdays at McDonald's
so obviously we do have some memories
and like something that bring us brings
us back to it I think it's also a little
bit more expensive compared to
McDonald's and maybe that's one of the
reasons why people would choose one
instead of the other even though there
are some Italian ingredients in the menu
Burger King is still pretty much
considered
the American option or like the American
fast food chain uh whereas McDonald's is
sort of got got rid of the American fast
food chain is just the fast food chain
if that makes sense they are the first
chain that has removed preservatives and
colorants from foods but there are quite
a few items that we've seen today that
look very shiny and like very colorful
and I would really like to know how do
you make your cheese so yellow without
colorance like why like how how is that
even possible naturally
Rivals I don't know would you consider
McDonald's rival that's like me saying
the Rocks My Rival like yeah Rivals but
like come on I don't think he's sweating
that I'm out there doing doing videos as
well uh there's no there's no no no
one's I mean Wendy's I
guess let's talk about prices in Italy a
Whopper is
€650 which is about about
$727 if you want to make that a meal
with a medium siiz drink and medium
fries that's going to cost you 11 and
that's about
$12.30 and in the US a Whopper will cost
you
$6.89 or six6 and 16 Euro byes I don't
know what the what is that sense all
right everyone relax it's cents there
you go all right so
€66 now that's a 6% decrease in price
how do you like that if you're making a
meal with a medium fries a medium drink
it will cost you
$128 or
€195 so it actually works out cheaper to
get a Whopper meal in the US rather than
in Italy but just byy a few cents 12
bucks uh I guess I'm used to it but you
come to think of it it's a lot more
expensive than what I initially thought
yeah I mean I don't think it's that good
good of a it's not like too expensive
but I think like 13 bucks or whatever 12
something plus tax for all this is like
H might as well get something better the
prices seem fair it is a little bit more
expensive than McDonald's but also the
burgers are a little bit bigger and it's
definitely almost half the price as like
a Five Guys I think € is fair but if you
start getting close to like 15 that's
where I think I would like to sit down
at a restaurant and that's probably the
price of like a main course like a
restaurant here in Milan
so1 was just below just below like the
restaurant line let's
say as the Whopper is Burger King's
number one best selling item with fall
we will compare them nutritionally in
Italy a Whopper contains 683 calories
our us Whopper contains all this if you
make that a meal by adding medium fries
and a medium Coke the total is this
making the grand total this the most
calorific item on the menu here is the
bacon King
3.0 at
1,342 calories that is a lot for a
burger our bacon King is also the most
calorific single item on the menu at
1,200 calories oof also at Burger King
you can get soft sered ice cream I
didn't get it because we've been in the
studio for a couple hours and it's very
and it would have melt how hot you ask
you can't tell but this shirt is
actually shirt that I work out and go
running in and if you can see the label
on there zoom in on that I'm wearing ath
Leisure wear for this job